bueno yo creo que el contexto del
concepto precede a la anexión o
recordación de crimea en 2014 si bien es
cierto que 2014 las relaciones entre
occidente y rusia se volvieron cada vez
más dificultosas la situación de
escalada actual obedece a una serie de
acontecimientos entre occidente y rusia
que elevaron incluso en eeuu el nivel de
vigilancia a una situación de potencial
crisis inminente lo que es realmente muy
peligroso yo creo que hay que entender
que occidente del punto de vista ha
llevado a una situación más allá de lo
recomendable al extender las líneas de
la otan a estas zonas geopolíticas rojas
de monstruo y desde este punto de vista
paramos
un territorio un país esencialmente
geopolítico terrestre cualquier
situación que implique acercarse
a líneas rojas como bielorrusia ucrania
y georgia implica una reacción en
términos de ganancia de poder que
incluyen la guerra de manera que el caso
del caso del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni también influyó en esta sección
pero básicamente para entender este
conflicto y su estado de gravedad hay
que encararlo desde la genética luego
hay otras cuestiones pero sin duda es la
geopolítica mixta tema muy sensible para
rusia el que actualmente ha llevado a la
situación a una situación casi de crisis
inminente bueno pues justamente hablando
esa crisis todos los actores en esta
escalada que son rusia ucrania estados
unidos de la otan se acusan entre sí de
la atención y cada quien tiene sus
propias razones como rebajar entonces
las tensiones cuando ninguno da un paso
atrás
bueno una de las características que ha
adquirido este concepto en los últimos
años estos si yo diría es nuevo desde
2014 hasta hoy es que se ha vuelto
prácticamente irreductible el conflicto
quedan muy pocas líneas como para
encauzar una negociación entre el
mandatario ruso que se ha mostrado un
poco frío en relación a la propuesta del
presidente norteamericano de abrir
negociaciones pero quedan algunas líneas
pero cada vez se están acortando más
puestos que rusia se ha iniciado
actividades militares en su frontera con
el donbass e incluso en crimea
pero también occidente ha llevado
adelante una serie de medidas que
preocupan anunciar el mismo lenguaje que
ha utilizado el presidente
estadounidense poco tiempo ha irritado
sobremanera
kremlin y las medidas que parece van a
llevar adelante eeuu en adelante son las
que preocupan a estados que
prácticamente en todos los frentes
pronuncia siente que occidente quiere
incrementar sanciones quieren presionar
a países de europa particularmente
alemania para que sean muy rebosa el
suministro de energía de luz de rusia a
europa quiere prácticamente sancionar a
rusia en ámbitos financieros
internacionales crear normas para
sancionar a rusia hacer
a rusia particularmente en el segmento
cibernéticos etcétera puesto que desde
mi punto de vista occidente considera
que se encuentra en una etapa de
debilidad y por lo tantos momentos de
presionado bueno pues muchas gracias por
su análisis interesante desde argentina
alberto julián roiter que nos acompaña
esta mañana france24